absichern gegen gefahr von außen dafür
sorgt die indonesische polizei beim g20
treffen doch manchmal kommt die gefahr
von innen der russische außenminister
sergei lavrov putins lautsprecher wird
von seiner indonesischen amtskollegin
neutral begrüßt so neutral wie das land
versucht sich zwischen dem westen und
russland zu positionieren wenn es um die
ukraine geht in dem gastgeber passt es
nicht als die frage ausgesprochen wird
die sich viele hier stellen
sie diesen krieg der zdf reporter von
dem sie kommt wird von
sicherheitskräften aus dem saal gebracht
russland ist nicht gekommen um fragen zu
beantworten sondern um botschaften zu
senden das wird auch später noch mal
sichtbar
auch sie hat die frage wann russland den
krieg beendet mit nach bali gebracht die
deutsche außenministerin annalena
baerbock sie ist gekommen weil sie
russland nicht die bühne überlassen will
das protokoll spielt mit im sitzungssaal
die sitzordnung gemacht die distanz
zwischen bernburg und lagrive auch
bildlich sichtbar die kameras dürfen
nicht dabei sein als lavrov als nummer
18 auf der liste seine rede hält direkt
danach verlässt er den sitzungssaal und
das treffen nummer 19 ist baerbock ihre
replik hört er sich nicht an
dass der russische außenminister einen
großen teil der verhandlungen hier nicht
im raum sondern außerhalb des raumes
verbracht hat unterstreicht dass es kein
millimeter an gesprächsbereitschaft der
russischen regierung derzeit gibt die
g20 sitzen zwar noch zusammen in einem
raum aber nicht alle reden noch
miteinander
ist diese zersplitterung jetzt
tatsächlich lager das westliche lager
geführt von usa und wir haben dann viele
die auf dem zaun sitzen sozusagen also
die ganzen möchte schwellenländer oder
auf der anderen seite haben wir russland
china und
autokratische flanke wie wichtig diese
flanke für russland ist zeigen auch die
bilder die laf beim treffen mit seinem
chinesischen amtskollegen inszeniert
eine für chinesische verhältnisse
geradezu herzliche begrüßung es ist
gekommen wie befürchtet statt austausch
haben sich die fronten bei g20-treffen
weiter verschärfen es geht im moment
nichts mehr zwischen russland und dem
westen das sergey lavrov nicht bereit
war den drei minuten zuzuhören die
deutsche außenministerin vorbereitet
hatte zeigt dass der weg zu ernsthaften
verhandlungen nach diesen g20-treffen
weiter ist als davor ja und darüber kann
ich mit unserer russland korrespondentin
für begaß sprechen die gerade dienstlich
für einige tage hier bei uns in berlin
ist schön guten tag kann wie bewerten
sie den wenig diplomatischen auftritt
des außenministers la france dass er
direkt nach der rede quasi geht also ich
glaube was wir da gesehen haben das war
ein testballon denn im november steht ja
die g20 gipfel der staats und
regierungschefs an und da ist aus
russischer sicht eben die frage sollte
präsident putin dort anreisen oder er
nicht also die frage ist das eine chance
diese internationale bühne die kann er
die nutzen um zum beispiel zu zeigen
dass russland eben gar nicht so isoliert
ist international wie das vielleicht
nach den sanktionen den anschein hat
oder droht dem russischen präsidenten
dort eine peinlichkeit indem er eben
ausgegrenzt wird und ich denke oder ich
gehe fest davon aus dass wir in nächster
zeit noch öfter tests dieser art sehen
werden wo russland also wissen will wie
geschlossen steht denn eigentlich nicht
nur g 20 auch die nato auch die eu wie
geschlossen stehen diese internationalen
gebilde dar und wo ergeben sich
vielleicht risse die russland dann auch
für sich nutzen kann
auch der russische präsident putin hat
vor fraktionsvorsitzenden sich noch mal
geäußert und er hat noch mal sich an den
westen gewandt was war seine botschaft
also bei dieser rede bin ich der
überzeugung dass ein teil der rede
tatsächlich auch an das heimische
publikum ging da hat er wiederholt was
wir seit beginn der militäroperationen
immer wieder von ihm gehört haben
nämlich dass sozusagen der einmarsch in
die ukraine unvermeidlich gewesen sei
und dass russland seine militärischen
ziele erfüllen werde daran finde ich
interessant wie häufig der präsident das
wiederholt da kann man schon den
eindruck bekommen dass es ihm darum geht
wirklich sicherzustellen vielleicht auch
ein bisschen zweifel auszuräumen bei
seinem publikum was sozusagen diese
beiden botschaften angeht also verfangen
die und an den westen gerichtet war
glaube ich der zentrale satz dass er
gesagt hat wir haben in der ukraine
gerade erst begonnen oder noch nicht mal
richtig begonnen alles weitere hat er
offen gelassen das ist verbunden mit der
warnung an den westen falls der westen
auf die idee kommen sollte dass die
sache auf dem schlachtfeld entschieden
werden sollte dann würde das in einer
tragödie enden für das ukrainische volk
also auch da ganz klar präsident putin
versucht ein bedrohungsszenario
aufzubauen auszubauen und zu erweitern
einschätzung von unserer russland
korrespondentin für begab vielen dank
und was ist alles für die internationale
diplomatie in zeiten des russland
ukraine krieges bedeutet darüber kann
ich jetzt mit dem außenpolitiker und
stellvertretenden fdp
fraktionsvorsitzenden alexander graf
lambsdorff sprechen guten tag
hallo schönen guten tag wie verstehen
sie putins worte was heißt das für den
westen
er macht weiter mit seinen drohungen er
macht ganz klar weiter mit seinem
kriegskurs und für den westen heißt es
dass die bisherige linie des
zusammenstehen es ja sogar das
zusammenrücken die weiterhin richtige
linie ist das heißt wir sollten die
westlichen verbündeten sonst noch darauf
reagieren
also ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig ist
was wir hier heute im deutschen
bundestag beschlossen haben wir haben
schweden und finnland das angebot
gemacht in die nato aufgenommen zu
werden das ist ja beim nato gipfel in
madrid aufs gleis gesetzt worden das gab
es stehende ovationen für finnland und
schweden und ich glaube dass die
unterstützung des bündnisses an der
ostflanke wichtig ist auch für unsere
baltischen freunde für polen für die
anderen länder dort aber am
allerwichtigsten ist natürlich die
fortgesetzte unterstützung für die
ukraine in ihrer verteidigung gegen
diesen schrecklichen russischen
angriffskrieg putin behauptet ja auch zu
sogenannten friedensgesprächen wie erst
nicht bereit zu sein wäre es dann ein
nur ein sogenannter frieden unter
russischen bedingungen oder könnte da
auch mehr möglich sein
ja das ist eine exzellente frage also
ein diktat frieden so heißt das unter
fachleuten ein diktat schreiben wo er
einfach alles bestimmen kann ist etwas
das kann die ukraine sicher nicht
akzeptieren und wir würden die ukraine
auch nicht ermutigen das zu tun wenn die
russische seite überraschenderweise
jetzt doch bereit sein sollte in
ernsthafte gespräche einzutreten dann
müsste die ukrainische seite wiederum
erklären dass auch sie dazu bereit ist
die ukraine ist die souveräne nation die
darf das allein entscheiden wir können
da nur raten aber das ist genau der
punkt russland wollte die souveräne die
staatliche existenz der ukraine
vernichten das ist offensichtlich nicht
gelungen kiew ist nach wie vor da
präsident selensky es offensichtlich
noch da und die russischen partnern die
ukrainischen streitkräfte sind
offensichtlich noch in den verteidigungs
gefechten so dass es wirklich eine
entscheidung der ukraine ist wann und
unter welchen bedingungen man in
gespräche eintritt dann schauen wir mal
auf g20 im november wenn die staats und
regierungschefs zusammenkommen putin ist
dort auch eingeladen wie soll man mit
ihm dort umgehen
ich glaube das ist da kein business as
usual geben kann man kann nicht so tun
als ob alles normal sei das haben wir ja
auch beim g20 außenministertreffen auf
bali jetzt gesehen die vorwürfe an den
russischen außenminister lavrov hat er
dadurch erwidert dass er einfach
abgehauen ist was mit putin im november
passieren wird werden wir mal sehen
vielleicht ist er ja auch zu nervös um
zu kommen weil er angst hat sich
anzustecken wir wissen dass noch nicht
nur wenn er kommt ist eines klar dann
kann es keine bilder
trauter gemeinsamkeit geben denn die
gibt es mit russland derzeit auch global
nicht